the burnt out flat in Nottingham is the
focus of this murder investigation
police are trying to establish who did
this and why yes I am the husband yes
the father of the children killed in the
fire had been in America but flew back
to London as soon as he could he spoke
briefly outside the flat before going to
see his wife in hospital I have to go
and see her I I mean I have no idea what
went wrong I just we were just coming
from London and I figured we were coming
he headed away to be by his wife's
bedside
this was what neighbors woke up to in
the early hours of Sunday smoke
billowing from the first floor windows
and firefighters trying to rescue the
family inside
after escaping from the flat below their
neighbor saw everything I just woke up
near the house was on fire I saw the
fire brigade drug out little kids I knew
they were gone
because the smoke the smoke was that
horrendous coming out as you can see it
was absolutely they had no chance she
was a lovely lady she's really kind of a
bit devastated because it's obviously
it's two little kids in it the loss of
young life two girls aged just three and
one has moved many here to bring flowers
the community is thinking of them that
we really care that we're really upset
that this has happened I think there's
just a sense of disbelief the whole
Community seems really subdued in the
local church a place for quiet
reflection as family and friends mourn
the loss of two young girls the police
investigation into their murders
continues
forensic investigation goes on those
inquiries will not stop because a
detectors will keep an open mind and we
will turn every single Stone to make
sure that this family get Justice
meanwhile a man is still being held in
custody on suspicion of murder Becky
Johnson Sky News Nottingham